[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue sur lcp public
sénat pour ce nouveau numéro de
parlement hebdo nous sommes comme
toujours avec mickaël zeze bonjour katia
bonjour a tous notre invité cette
semaine jean marc germain bonjour
bonjour vous êtes députée socialiste des
hauts-de-seine candidats pour les
élections législatives qui arrive
bientôt très très vite on va revenir
avec vous sur les temps forts politique
de la semaine notamment les investitures
pour les législatives la république en
marche des manuels macron a dévoilé une
liste de 428 noël ne plaît pas à tout le
monde
on parlera aussi de la recomposition à
droite et à gauche bien entendu et de
françois hollande emmanuel macron côte à
côte pour des commémorations sorte de
passation de pouvoir avant l'heure mais
d'abord l'actualité politique domine
évidemment par le casse-tête des
investitures pour les législatives
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
428 investiture en marche l'appareil a
été respectée et la moitié des candidats
est issu de la société civile des
novices mais aussi certains noms un peu
plus connu françois chevret c'était le
dossier le plus épineux a tranché manuel
valls ne sera pas investi mais il n'aura
pas de candidat en marche face à lui
dans l'essonne au moment où nous
rassemblons nous estimons qu on ne
claque pas la porte au nez
un ancien premier ministre de la
république qui en quelque sorte dit j'ai
envie de vous rejoindre d'être utile si
je vous avais répondu nous allons tout
faire pour combattre monsieur valls
vous m'auriez dit peut-être comment est
ce que cela est tenable
avec la philosophie de rassemblement que
vous portez en tout le mouvement d'
emmanuel macron a reçu dix neuf mille
candidatures sur les 428 dossiers
retenus pour le moment autant de femmes
que d'hommes une moyenne d'âge de 46 ans
la moitié n'a jamais eu de mandat
politique alors que 26 sont des députés
sortants car tous socialistes mais
richard ferrand se dit encore ouvert à
accueillir des parlementaires de droite
il y a un certain nombre d'élus
républicains ou deux candidats
républicains qui ont déclaré vouloir
aider le président de la république
par conséquent nous allons prendre en
compte si certains en prennent la d
non parce qu'il leur faut un peu de
temps eh bien nous voulons être en
capacité d'accueillir le rassemblement
le plus large possible en conformité
avec notre adn avec notre origine les
candidats et l'équipe de campagne seront
présentés samedi au quai branly à paris
les derniers investis devraient être
connus au plus tard mercredi prochain
jean-marie jamin le renouvellement façon
macron ça vous inspire quoi
écoutez on travaille tout ce
renouvellement nous mêmes nous avons
présenté des candidats avec 60% têtes
nouvelles des on en a beaucoup moins
parlé donc je constate c'est une belle
opération de communication mais quand on
regarde derrière au fond c'est des
profils très classique et c'est
peut-être une méthode aussi un peu
ringarde je trouve que vous ayez neuf
personnes comme dans une entreprise qui
décide qui de qui est candidat l'idée
que chacun puisse candidate et moi je
trouvais que c'était une belle idée et
on se rend compte au bout du bout que
les gens sont issus de cabinets
ministériels la plupart ou était déjà
dans un parti puis on changera t-il
derrière tout cela encore je le dise
n'aime pas me prononcer ce mot il j'aime
bien respecté mes adversaires donc nous
aurons dans les 577 circonscriptions des
adversaires mais je trouve que toute
cette mousse qui est fait
touchant l'innovation elle est un peu
vous savez moi j'ai été investi par
exemple
après avoir présenté ma candidature
l'avoir défendue par des femmes et des
hommes d'en bas et ensuite il ya au
niveau de notre formation politique
un travail qui est fait pour
rééquilibrer les choses pour qu'on ait
la parité pour que des femmes et des
sommes issues de la diversité soient
représentés et puis moi vous savez je
pense que quand on est élu local
puisqu'on dit il ya 52 % des gens qui
n'ont jamais été élu c'est aussi
respectable que quand on est chef
d'entreprise quand on est élu local
on a des revenus très faibles ont passé
samedi et dimanche à se dévouer pour les
autres donc moi j'aime pas faire cette
pause avait compris et je voudrais vous
parler du cas de manuel valls
il n'y aura pas de candidat de la france
la république en marche face à manuel
valls
est-ce que vous parti socialiste il y
aura un candidat face à l'ancien premier
ministre
tc au premier secrétaire d'en décider
d'eux
aux essais à nos instances mais je
voudrais dire deux choses d'abord je
pense que les français ils aiment bien
qu'on soit fidèle à soi même et à son
histoire
pas comme on change de bord pour être
réélu à tout prix auquel n'a pas être
moi je ne sais pas si je serai réélu ça
aurait été plus facile pour moi d'aller
taper à la porte des manuels macron que
je connais très bien de richard ferrand
qui est un ami intime et lui dire écoute
j à 32% de ton côté et huit pour cent du
côté de benoît hamon
est-ce que vous pouvez pas vendre
nouvelle vague oui mais je vous parle de
moi pour vous dire comment j'aurais
souhaité que manuel valls réfléchissent
pas se dire je veux me faire réélire et
donc je joue avec des villes quête voilà
est plutôt d'être fidèle à son histoire
qu'est une histoire de social libéral
sans lui s'il est le socialisme c'est
pas une sanction parce que pour le coup
pour en marche
c'est vraiment je ne sais pas comment on
dit ça n'entre dans des termes polis
mais il aurait été plus clair que le
mouvement mar 10 puisqu'il la demande et
bien tu rejoindre majorité
présidentielle et tu quittes le parti
socialiste eut peut rester socialiste et
de déclarer socialisme et apporter une
formation de politiques et des règles et
tuent les respecte la cette espèce de de
demi-mesures qui est en réalité une
pleine mesure puisqu'il aura pas de
candidat face à lui c'est comme s'il
était candidat pour en marche
en réalité puisqu'il revendique en plus
dans la majorité présentielle donc voilà
j'aime pas bien cette situation n'est
pas claire vous puisque vous parlez de
vous à titre personnel vous souhaitez
qui accroît dida face alors si après
ministre question moi je ne veux pas me
prononcer pour une circonscription de
l'essonne moi je sais ce que je fais
dans ma propre circonscription je serai
candidat il y aura un candidat en marche
et il y aura un beau débat démocratique
ça va au fond qui sera le plus utile de
ce candidat là de moi même ou du
candidat sur 7 6 à 24 députés sortants
socialistes qui ont été investis sous le
label république en marge est ce que ça
vous étonne ce qu'il n'y a pas un peu
beaucoup de gosses quand même dans
marche
il ya deux sortes de parlementaires dans
ces 24 il y en a qui comme richard
ferrand
ou corinne erhel qui est décédé
malheureusement par la faim derrière qui
sont allés de manière sincère compris
des risques d'ailleurs à l'époque parce
que ça voulait dire même si on l'a pas
fait risquer d'être exclu du parti
socialiste puis en a d'autres qui l'ont
fait un peu de la manière nous expliquer
pour manuel valls est à dire qu ils sont
collés au secours de la victoire et ça
je pense que les français n'apprécient
pas alors justement vous parliez de tout
à l'heure du parti socialiste vous
organisez bien évidemment écouter le
premier secrétaire de votre partition
christophe cambadélis parler de ces
élections législatives le parti
socialiste est prêt à discuter avec
toutes les formations pour présenter un
candidat ou une candidate commune dans
les circonscriptions le front national a
fait plus de 60 %
nous le disons à la fois aux dirigeants
de france insoumise et aurait dit aux
dirigeants de le rassemblement autour du
président de la république c'est à dire
la république en marche
voilà pour les propos de jean christophe
cambadélis mais on a bien compris que le
programme du ps pour ces élections
ce n'est plus le programme du candidat
benoît hamon exit notamment leur revenu
universel l'écologie la taxe d elle n'a
pu rien vous simplifiez bourgoin parce
que moi qui ai contribué à l'écriture de
cette plateforme est bien connu à ce que
tout ce que benoît hamon avait défendu
que je crois juste soit dedans vous
parlez du revenu universel par exemple
il est dit très clairement que le compte
personnel d'activité qui permet d'avoir
des droits à la formation ou autres
inclut un volet revenus c'est ce que
voulait benoît hamon font que les
étudiants puissent étudier en ayant des
moyens et soit pas exclue du rsa et que
quand on dit ça pour un groupe leur
programme eh bien on tombe pas dans un
trou en dessous de 800 euros donc moi je
chacun au sein du parti socialiste
moi j'aurais souhaité qui est le mot
revenu universel qu'on l'assumé
pleinement
mais en même temps il ya l'idée en tout
cas la première étape qui avait défendu
benoist
qui dit et j'aurais souhaité aussi qu'on
parle de la sortie du nucléaire parce
que je pense qu'il faut s'organiser pour
ça que c'est bon pour le pays
mais en même temps on assume pleinement
la première étape qui est la loi de
transition énergétique et qui est une
marche très haute à monter 50% n'y a pas
tout le monde peut vivre et vivre bien
et fièrement avec ce programme est le
deuxième chose qui était très importante
pour moi ça va et qu'on a failli sonner
la fin du parti socialiste mardi
et moi j'ai contribué avec les amis de
martine aubry s'est trouvé un compromis
est ce que j'étais attaché c'est qu'on
défende une position d'autonomie les
défendu moi même d'ailleurs en tant que
parlementaire certains ont rappelé à
frondeurs moi c'était simplement dire
une chose toute bête et on vote ce qui
est bon pour le pays et qui est conforme
aux idées comporte c'est qu'on croit
juste depuis jaurès les idées
socialistes
et puis on ne vote pas ce qu'on pense ne
pas être bon je ne voterai pas et les
électeurs doivent le savoir
les ordonnances macron sur le travail
parce que je pense que le tall code du
travail très important non je serai un
opposant à la loi travail sous cette
forme là c'est à dire par des
ordonnances et en diminuant la place du
code du travail dans les porter à
l'assemblée un combat avec vos collègues
laurent baumel etc que deviennent ceux
que ce groupe que vous incarnez aussi
les frondeurs que devient que seront
utiles que deviendront-ils demain avec
la sécurité 1 c'était un combat ou en
tout cas une attitude de femmes et
d'hommes hull d'esprits libres pas un
groupe qui cherchent à s'opposer
moi j'ai voté avec une immense fierté
par exemple ce que nous avons fait sur
la pénibilité pour les femmes et les
hommes qui ont des métiers pénibles
puissent travers de partir plus tôt en
retraite dans le combat cgv haute
résonance entre ce sera dans ce vraiment
là contre des choses très précises et
devant les électeurs autre sujet la
suppression de l'impôt sur la fortune
pour les ultra riches ceux qui ont
beaucoup d'action je pense que c'est pas
bon pour le pays parce que on sait bien
que on peut toujours ce avec un
patrimoine d'action et que donc c'est
pas vraiment pour aider l'économie et
que c'est très injuste
un moment où vous avez des femmes et des
hommes plus de 50% des français quand
ils sont à la caisse du supermarché cinq
semaines il conte à 10 euros près vous
pouvez pas dans ces conditions faire des
cadeaux qui seront en réalité cinq cent
mille euros pour les 1000 personnes les
plus riches de notre pays
l'avenir du parti socialiste on en parle
avec vous ma question vous avez rejoint
fait dans un instant mathilde c'est à
vous bonjour bonjour jean marc germain
vous avez signé cette semaine la tribune
d'anne hidalgo qui a lancé son propre
mouvement qui s'intitule dès demain
c'était mercredi benoît hamon il va lui
aussi lancé son propre mouvement vous
étiez son directeur de campagne
est ce que vous allez rejoindre ce
mouvement bien sûr oui vous savez notre
formation politique faut pas se cacher
derrière des grands discours elle a
connu une défaite lourde avec six et
demi pour cent à la présidentielle donc
elle doit se reconstruire
mais au fond toutes les formations
politiques dans leur histoire ont eu des
moments difficiles elle se reconstruira
moi je considère ce que fait anne
hidalgo avec beaucoup de personnalité de
la société civile je pense à quelqu'un
que les français connaissent bien yann
arthus bertrand avec des belles
personnes du parti socialiste ou de la
gauche comme christiane taubira martine
aubry et bien d'autres je pense à
françois bonneau président de la région
centre c'est quelque chose qui est
absolument essentiel de s'oxygéner
dépasser notre formation politique mais
c'est pas pour la remplacer c'est
justement pour lui donner de l'air et
l'accord on reconstruire en étant et à
l'intérieur et à l'extérieur de même que
benoît hamon qui va lancer une
initiative au mois de juillet le 1er
juillet c'est absolument essentiel qui
le fait qu'il le fasse parce que malgré
son échec
on voit bien qu'il a porté sur
l'écologie vous en parlais tout à
l'heure sur le travail les mutations du
travail il faut s'en occuper trouver des
solutions ou sur la démocratie
les français ont apprécié et ont
apprécié sa personnalité donc je
considère que benoît ressemble anne
hidalgo obama d'hidalgo ils ont nos
responsables ne font pas
c'est comme dans une forêt il faut pas
qu'ils aient une tête et tout le monde
se range derrière il faut qu'ils aient
des beaux arbres et là il ya deux
graines donc son retour des chapelles
les quatre ce que chacun porte des
initiatives et qu'ils le fassent ils se
sont vus bien sûr avant avant cela ils
se sont parlé et ils ont tous les deux
la volonté d'apporter des nous des idées
nouvelles des pratiques nouvelles en
restant fidèle au sein du ps pas en
dehors parce que ça se voit quand même
trop ce parti cdc des réseaux c'est des
mouvements qui se veulent être au dessus
du parti socialiste est dans la société
vous avez 200 personnalités de la
société civile qui ne veulent pas partir
une compétition non non il n'y a pas eu
de noirmont qui a pas du tout secret y a
pas du tout de compétition vous verrez
mais il ya des frais engagés je mets la
construction et du lierse et socialistes
font qu' il faut que mille fleurs
s'épanouissent à gauche et c'est comme
ça qu'on leur donnera envie aux femmes
et aux hommes de gauche quand pas envie
que la gauche disparaît c'est justement
le ps est très affaibli les élections
législatives s'annoncent
quand même très dur sans financement
avec encore moins d'élus est ce que le
ps peut vraiment survivre à cette
décomposition en cours je crois que oui
et vous savez depuis quelques temps mais
habitué aux surprises dans les élections
un primaire nous vous parfois bonnes
pour nous parfois mauvaise et ben moi je
vous annonce une bonne surprise
en tout cas pour nous pour les élections
législatives
si il ya d'ailleurs pas besoin de se
créer de grandes illusions et je pense
qu'on va avoir en fait un parlement qui
va avoir trois groupes à peu près de
même taille
les socialistes main je me lance ce soir
ce soir cet après-midi pense qu'on aura
à peu près 150 députés socialistes et
pas comme on nous prédit aujourd'hui
avec des idées tout simple cette
estimation sur vous savez il ya des il
ya des simulations que l'on peut faire
on sait qu'il ya une partie de notre
électorat qui c'est qui est parti avec
monsieur macron parce qu'il ne voulait
pas avoir à choisir entre fillon et le
pen et nous l'a dit nous le redis et
puis on a une partie qui est parti chez
mélenchon parce que il sentait que
c'était le voile
le vote qu'elle ait donné le plus
possible de puissance à gauche et il
hésite et entre amants et mélenchon est
donc si vous avez 20 % par exemple de
chacun de ces deux électorats qui se
disent finalement avec les choix clair
que j'évoquais tout à l'heure
constructif voilà ce qu'on propose
vigilant voilà ce sur quoi on se posera
si vous votez pour nous vous ne payez
pas les bienvenus
je pense que c'est 20% d'un côté 20%
d'autres un cinquième de ceux des
électorats et s'ils reviennent vers nous
faites vos calculs vous arriverez à 150
députés aux journalistes vous ne payez
pas les six et demi de l'élection
présidentielle
non je crois pas vous savez regardez par
exemple la popularité de celui qui l'a
incarné et reste une personnalité parmi
les cinq ou six préféré des français
préféré à gauche et tous les gens nous
disent benoît hamon c'est vraiment
quelqu'un de bien
quelqu'un d'honnête et il a été
courageux jusqu'au bout derrière qui se
relaient tous deux leur de compenser
important d'être constance dans la vie
jean-marc jamana la question vous
concernant vous représenter aux
législatives dans les hauts-de-seine
en cas de défaite vous faites quoi en
cas de défaite au 1er tour au deuxième
tour après si vous n'êtes pas réélu vous
faites quoi moi je vais retourner
travailler
j'ai un métier j'ai envie de continuer
ma vie professionnelle j'ai mis entre
parenthèses pour cinq ans parlait de
renouvellement moi j'étais le
renouvellement la dernière fois je
n'avais exercer aucun mandat je
considère que je le suis encore cette
fois ci j'ai une suppléante qui acquit
ya trente ans mais je pense que dans la
vie il faut faire des mandats il faut
alterner de la vie politique l'exercice
de mandats et de la vie professionnelle
ça vous intéresserait pas par exemple
écoutez je ne sais pas ma nature de
sauter de mandat en mandat mais en même
temps même pour cette élection je me
suis beaucoup posé de questions j'ai
discuté avec ceux qui me soutiennent
localement pour savoir si j'allais me
représenter parce que j'avais envie
aussi de favoriser le renouvellement
ils m'ont demandé de le faire parce
qu'ils m'ont dit dans cette période très
difficile on a besoin de quelqu'un
d'expérience on a besoin de toi les gens
apprécient dans la circonscription près
d'ailleurs vous évoquez ça tout à
l'heure moi je suis j'ai vu les
candidats en marche
dans ma circonscription beaucoup
d'ailleurs sont proches et était proche
est et reste proche mais je suis très
surpris et qui ait pas de candidat
investi dans ma circonstances je sais
pas je ne sais pas pourquoi où il va y
en avoir un sens peut-être un candidat
modem c'est peut-être pour ça d'ailleurs
que c'est mal qu'un mais moi ce qui me
ce qui me frappe c'est que j'y aille à
des il ya des femmes et des hommes qui
sont très motivés très engagé et qu'on
tout à fait les compétences et qui
pourraient être investis parmi ceux qui
habitent dans la circonscription qui
vivait donc je suis très surpris que ce
parti politique et qui veut se donner
une idée de modernité alors même qu'il a
des femmes et des hommes compétentes
eh bien ils sont en train de faire des
tractations soient pour mais justement
gabon soit pour may et les tractations
s'avèrent mais bon soit pour mettre des
gants avec emballante formation
politique soit pour ce qui est un peu
pour le coup détestable de dire madame
vallaud belkacem elle a soutenu amont
donc je lui mets un candidat en marché
pital au sein d'un parti politique on
choisit pas les candidats de d'autre
part un gendarme en affirmant quand vous
regardez cette guéguerre qui a lieu
maintenant
aujourd'hui entre françois bayrou et les
équipes de re marche mais je trouve que
ça fait pas un moderne
c'est même très décevant alors je
m'exprime pour une formation à laquelle
je n'appartiens pas mais j'ai j'imagine
tous ceux que je croise et qui ont cru
qu'il suffisait d'envoyer son cv est que
ce seraient les meilleurs qui serait
pris l'immense déception qui doit y
avoir en se disant finalement les dés
sont un peu pipés merci mathilde pour
cette analyse alors on va parler d'un
homme qui a fait beaucoup parler de lui
aussi cette semaine jean marc germain
c'est jean luc mélenchon qui a décidé de
se présenter à marseille c'est à dire
dans la circonscription du socialiste
patrick mennucci
j'ai une question est ce que jean luc
mélenchon est plus dangereux pour
l'avenir du parti socialiste emmanuel
macron palme écoutez là aussi jean luc
mélenchon importer une démarche
innovante comme l'avait fait emmanuel
macron en marche on sen soumis c'est une
façon faire de la politique assure cette
démarche là que j'ai apprécié comme
l'avait fait en hidalgo à paris martine
aubry avec le parti socialiste ségolène
en rêve tous donc c'est pas ton parent a
inventé la poudre mais enfin ils ont
fait des choses que vous remplacez et
donc c'est pour ça je commence par
s'excuser moi mais je vais répondre à
christian et je suis aussi très déçu
parce que moi je vous remplacez
personnes moi je considère qu'il ya une
place pour le parti communiste pour une
gauche radicale comme celle qu'incarne
jean luc mélenchon qu'il a des idées
fortes que finalement qui est des gens
dans le pays qu'ils soient anti
européens comme ça c'est bien
je porte l'idée que l'écologie politique
doit exister par être absorbés par les
autres formations politiques donc moi je
crois que la gauche et les belles et la
politique
plus généralement elle est belle quand
elle est diverse et quand chaque
composante est accueillante à l'égard
des idées des autres et moi c'est ça
dont je rêve c'est pour ça que j'aime
j'aime bien c'est pour les gars de jean
luc louis et c'est pour ça que
j'apprécie la démarche de nidal go comme
celle de benoît hamon parce que c'est
pas nous le parti socialiste on veut
tout pour nous c'est non on a envie de
travailler ensemble et on le montre dès
maintenant même quand c'est très
difficile alors on va voir maintenant ce
qu'a été la semaine des républicains qui
ont eux aussi présenter leurs projets
pour ces législatives
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un plan de bataille à un projet
d'alternance certes mais édulcoré par
rapport à celui qui avait été présenté
pour la présidentielle on voit ça avec
céline martèlent leur plan de bataille
est prêt pour gagner les législatives
les républicains mettent en avant leurs
propositions en faveur du pouvoir
d'achat
retour des heures supplémentaires
défiscalisées plus d'augmentation de la
tva et surtout une baisse de 10% de
l'impôt sur le revenu la droite espère
ainsi renouer avec les classes
populaires et marquer sa différence avec
emmanuel macron il ya une augmentation
cacher des impôts chez emmanuel macron
parce que personne n'est vraiment
insister sur le sujet peut-être parce
qu'il a pas eu de débat cela siège et
l'augmentation de la csg c'est plus de
20 milliards d'euros
les républicains se servent aussi de ce
projet pour renforcer leur alliance avec
lui des é
ils veulent serrer les rangs à l'heure
où plusieurs ténors de la droite et du
centre pourrait rejoindre le
gouvernement du nouveau président les
centristes ont obtenu des concessions
la suppression des cinq cent mille
postes de fonctionnaires prévue par
françois fillon en un quinquennat est
désormais étalée sur sept ans il ya
beaucoup de mesures auxquelles nous
tenions qui n'avait pas été arbitré
favorablement par françois fillon qui
aujourd'hui ont pu être mises finalement
ce projet il permet de rassembler
l'ensemble les centristes la droite
modérée la jupe et l'a dit lui-même
et puis ceux qui sont aussi ils ont
raison partisans d'un rétablissement de
l'autorité de l'état d'une fermeté un
effort sur la défense nationale sur la
police sur la justice sur la sécurité la
justice
les républicains reprennent les mesures
de la présidentielle dix mille policiers
et gendarmes supplémentaires
construction de seize mille places de
prison et l'abaissement de la majorité
pénale à 16 ans avec ce projet censé
représenter toutes les tendances de la
droite et du centre
les républicains espèrent maintenir
l'unité au moins jusqu'aux résultats des
élections législatives
jean-marc demain je vous dit tout à
l'heure que vous espériez un groupe
socialiste fort à l'assemblée est ce que
vous pensez que la droite va réussir à
maintenir son unité jusqu'aux
législatives et qu'il y aura aussi une
droite un groupe fort de la droite
je pense que monsieur mac os on va tout
faire pour en détacher quelques-uns et
c'est la raison pour laquelle il reste
autant de députés aux deux candidats qui
n'ont pas été désignés mais en même
temps qu effectivement la droite va
constituer un groupe important au fond
il ya eu quatre blocs à l'élection
présidentielle le front national la
droite le en marche et la gauche y aura
trois blogs vraiment je pense d'ailleurs
de taille presque égal à l'assemblée
nationale et donc non mais c'est pas la
majorité il avant de savoir si c'est
facile ou pas donc cela la politique va
se partager en trois il va y avoir la
droite il va y avoir le centre parce
qu'au fond c'est un parti centriste s'en
trouvent au centre droite qu'est devenu
le parti de monsieur macron et la gauche
et notamment avec beaucoup de
socialistes parce que vous parliez des
jean luc mélenchon sa stratégie jusqu'au
boutisme ne jamais vouloir discuter avec
personne va faire qu'il aura très peu de
parlementaires à l'assemblée
peut-être qu'il sera le seul ou qu'ils
sont quatre ou cinq et qu'en revanche
nous parce que les français nous
connaissent nous apprécient nous
considèrent comme courageux bas ne pas
quitter le parti socialiste quand ça va
mal je pense qu'ils nous feront
confiance donc vous aurez c3 c3 force là
et c'est ça que je veux dire aux
français qui nous écoutent
c'est que leur vote est très important
il y avait un chauffeur de taxi et qui
me disait on va enfin pouvoir dire ce
qu'on pense à cette élection parce qu'on
n'a pas pu le faire la présentielle je
crois que c'est ça vraiment l'enjeu
il faut leur dire vous avez la
possibilité de mettre plus de social et
d'écologie en votant pour jean marc
germain dans ma circonscription pour un
socialiste de mettre plus de droits à
cette élection c'est pour sa 15ème tour
de l'élection présidentielle j'aime pas
cette expression parce que ça voudrait
dire je reconnais pas les résultats de
l'élection présidentielle
monsieur macro est élu et je souhaite
que la france réussisse avec lui à sa
tête
je la considère comme il ya une élection
qu'elle choisit le président d'adp de la
république et je souhaite c'est qu'il
soit plutôt un père de la nation que
quelqu'un qui va décider de tout partout
tout le temps notamment la place ici on
est au parlement du parlement
je souhaite qu'un parlement qui joue
pleinement son rôle et donc du pouvoir
c'est le tour du choix de l'avenir de la
france
alors qu'on la présidentielle est-elle
autour du choix du président de la
france et je crois que c'est très
important et pb et donc c'est une belle
élection de du réputé pour la victoire
me rend mais surtout pour la première
fois sous la vème république les
français en choix entre la droite qui au
fond à garder le projet de filles ont un
tout petit peu rabattu mais trois cent
mille fonctionnaires en moins mais une
prise une privatisation rampante de la
sécurité sociale un projet centriste qui
place l'individu au centre mais dont
nous on désigne on dénonce le risque
finalement en donnant l'illusion de
croire chacun va pouvoir débrouiller
tout seul eh bien les plus faibles ne
seront pas aussi bien traités que les
plus forts et puis nous on va passer à
cette fin de semaine et puis a résumé un
petit peu de cette semaine qui ont été
aussi marquée par des commémorations je
vous proposer quelques images jean marc
germain regardé c'était françois
hollande emmanuel macron côte-à-côte
cérémonie dans les jardins du luxembourg
notamment pour la journée nationale du
souvenir de l'abolition de l'esclavagé
un peu plus tôt dans la semaine c'était
aux commémorations du 8 mai écoutez
d'ailleurs ce que nous confiait dans les
jardins du luxembourg françois hollande
s'est terminée avec les cérémonies comme
président de la république
mais la politique elle est simple tout
citoyen quelle a été sa place quelques
était son rôle
quelle que soit sa position doit avoir à
l'esprit la politique c'est l'avis de la
france d'un public c'est les choix
essentiels pour le pays et donc nul ne
peut se mettre à l'écart et il ya
toujours une utilité il faut se poser
cette même question qui revient sans
cesse comment puis je être utile à mon
pays et bien c'est à cette question que
je vais répondre maintenant réfléchir en
travaillant en produisant et en
intervenant quand ça me paraît très
heureux françois hollande qui se rendra
dimanche après la passation de pouvoir
au siège du parti socialiste
de retour à la maison vous l'accueillez
à bras ouverts écoutez d'abord un
commentaire faux sur vos images moi
j'aime bien cette période où il ya deux
présidents de la république
j'avais bien aimé le 8 mai avec sarkozy
et hollande et j'ai trouvé que cette
image était belle aussi parce qu'au fond
c'est un monde que la république la
démocratie c'est pas la guerre on élit
des dirigeants et un moment donné il
incarne la france et il se passe le
pouvoir dans de bonnes dans de bonnes
conditions indiqué sur france culture
françois hollande qui viennent au parti
socialiste
moi je suis fidèle à cette formation je
pense qu'elle a une longue histoire je
sais qu'elle est ni soir vers elle mais
elle en a aussi une longue devant la
belle idée qu'il n'y a pas de liberté
sans égalité la solidarité quand il
reprend les si je vous répondrais que
non il reprend pas la maison amélie
monde qu'il est fidèle à cette maison là
et moi j'ai apprécié ce geste comme
mitterrand l'avait fait en son temps
continuité institutionnelle vous dites
mais aussi continuité de politiques
quelque part tout cas fidélité aux élus
on change pas de camp en fonction des
opportunités on a on reste pas droit
dans ses bottes mais en tout cas fidèle
à son histoire - vous savez quand je
m'interroge je pense par exemple à ses
ouvriers qui sont morts pour défendre la
semaine 2
depuis la journée de huit heures et le
repos dominical et je me dis qu'en leur
nom
même si c'est difficile on n'a pas le
droit de renoncer comme on n'a pas le
droit de renoncer à se comporter les
combats féministes et tous les combats
qui font qu'il ya plus de justice
sociale dans le pays
on va terminer cette émission avec une
image cet hommage qui a été rendu cette
semaine à corinne erhel la députée
socialiste des côtes d'armor qui est
décédé brutalement la semaine dernière
lors d'un meeting de soutien à emmanuel
macron le président élu emmanuel mâcon
était présent à ses obsèques à lannion
en bretagne ainsi que de nombreux
députés jean marc germain vous la
connaissiez quelques mots au sujet de
corinne erhel voter oui c'était une
parlementaire qui travaillait beaucoup
très apprécié de tout le monde à gauche
comme à droite et que je l' ai dit tout
à l'heure qui s'était engagé avec
beaucoup de conviction dans le soutient
emmanuel macron elle était faisait
partie des deux premiers et je regrette
qu'elle n'ait pas pu avoir la joie de
cette victoire pour elle même si c'était
pas mon choix moi je sais qu'elle y
tenait beaucoup et j'espère que là où
elle a pu voir ça et avoir le sentiment
du devoir accompli
merci vous remercie beaucoup et l'on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine pour une
nouvelle émission sur elle s'était vu
que c'est un très bon type de programme
du job
[Musique]